uh Pam and I would sometimes hum the
same high-pitched note and try to get
Dwight to make an appointment with an
ear doctor
and uh Pam called it
pretendinitis
would you like to pull prank on handy um
I'm kind of in the middle yes please
okay good stay right here
[Music]
oh sorry about that move tuna
are there any messages no
no
[Music]
[Applause]
um large tuna have you seen my cell
phone device
my home is someone just calling right
now
there is a call
fine I'll just go sit at my desk and be
quiet
sorry I annoyed you with my friendship
[Music]
sorry that a lot of people here
for some reason think it's funny to
steal someone's personal property and
hide it from them
here's a little news flash it's not
funny
in fact it's pretty freaking unfunny
ow
stop it stop what you're talking about
me in Morse code
you know what joke's on you because I
know Morse code
that's what we're doing
and are a very limited free time and
with our very limited budget we went and
got a nanny and then we went out and
took a class on a very outmoded and very
unnecessary form of communication just
so we could talk about you in front of
you
yep that's exactly what we did
it all started when Dwight was tapping
his foot against the leg of his desk
when I asked him to stop he said I will
when you lose the baby weight
very well I must have imagined it I
apologize
detonator
Detonator where
Michael
Jim
are you clicking a detonator
it's a pin Michael come on get back to
work Dwight please
fine
hey Tap Away
excuse me how long is the wait for a
table for two
I would never ever serve you not in a
million billion years
it's a nice tax I know it belonged to my
grandfather
he was buried in it so
family heirloom
so what's the deal we gotta pay for our
own drinks come on it'll be fun and
besides I'm a roulette expert impossible
roulette is not a game of skill it is a
game of chance
I could always kind of win at roulette
oh really
mm-hmm
how would you do that
mind control
you can't be serious
are you serious ever since I was a
little kid
like eight or nine I could
sort of control things with my mind
I don't believe you continue
it was just little things you know like
I could make something shake or I could
make a marble fall off the counter you
know just little things
that's ridiculous you know what uh why
don't you move that coat rack
excuse me everyone attention in the
office please Jim is about to prove his
telekinetic powers and he needs absolute
silence go ahead
okay I'll try
oh my God
morning Dwight
who are you
who am I
I'm Jim we've been working together for
12 years
we're jebed White
you're not Jim Jim's not Asian you
seriously never noticed hey hats off to
you for not seeing race
all right then Jim uh why don't you tell
me about that sale that you made
yesterday
uh Wellington systems saw them 10 cases
of 24 pound letter stock or were you
talking about Creek or Murphy because I
didn't close that one yet but I'm hoping
I've got a voicemail from Paul Krieger
waiting for me
complete enter your password
you have one new message no no no no no
that is sensitive information only for
employees not Outsiders cut it out I'm
trying to work you don't work here
you're not Jim Jim I got us at dinner
reservation Greco 7 30. oh great can't
wait
Jim's at the dentist this morning and
Steve is an actor friend of ours I don't
know who you are
not Jim
this is Jim
oh dude oh how did
ah don't listen I was thinking that it
might be a good idea if you and I have
formed an alliance
because of the downsizing
an alliance it might be a good idea yeah
help each other out
do you want to form an alliance with me
absolutely I do good an alliance oh yeah
what does that even mean I think it has
something to do with Survivor but I'm
not sure
I know that it involves spying on people
and we may build a fort hey
hey hi Pam listen can I talk to you for
a second about
the paper products
did you tell Pam about the alliance no
just now oh no no Dwight no I'm using
her for the alliance who knows the most
information about this office Pam right
it's good good pursue this I'm trying to
you see what I'm doing but listen I'm
gonna have to talk to her a lot all
right and they're maybe chatting and
giggling and you got to just pretend to
ignore it wipe it away done all right
he's in a box I am he's in a box he's
downstairs in a box on the floor near
the shelves
I'm serious go down there and work your
magic
hey where are you
yeah we were supposed to meet here
what
oh my gosh
that ties in perfectly with something
that Michael was telling me earlier
I just don't know what some of the
people in like accounting are gonna do
it said specifically that
Michael and Jan definitely made out oh
maybe more
oh also it is Thursday but do I think
it's Friday so we'll keep that going